>>Joe Malin: Hello, and welcome once again
to Android Developer Office Hours.
My name is Joe Malin, and I have with me today
DevRel people: Alexander Lucas, Reto Meier,
Trevor Johns, and from Google engineering,
Francesco-- Sorry, I screwed up his first
name.
>>Francesco Nerieri: Francesco Nerieri.
>>Malin: Thank you, Francesco.
[laughter] The first thing we want to do is
find out, with a little intro from Francesco,
about Google Cloud Messaging, which is a new
service that we introduced at Google IO.
Go ahead.
>>Nerieri: Hi everyone.
Google Cloud Messaging is a new service which
is evolution from the old C2DM service, which
allows you to send messages from the Cloud
to the device.
This is an important service if you want to
avoid polling, which saves battery life because
your application doesn't have to work out
the radio every X seconds or minutes due to
polling.
But when the data is available on the Cloud,
then the server can send it down to the device.
Improvement regards scalability, performance.
There is a new set of features for APIs that
allows you to send multi-cast messages.
With one request, you can send up to 1000
messages.
Up to one message to up to 1000 different
devices.
Time to leave, so your messages can expire.
And so on and so forth, a bit more.
Other APIs.
>>Malin: Please send in or call in your questions.
With that, we'll start now with the questions
from Moderator.
The first question is: why doesn't Google
provide developers with more stats for the
downloads, such as how users found the app,
keywords, categories, related apps, etcetera.
>>Trevor Johns: All right.
[electronic music playing]
>>Malin: Okay, thank you, Trevor.
Next question, also about Google Play: how
come selling apps on Google Play is still
impossible for most of the world because of
country limitations?
Why is Google being so opaque on this matter?
>>Johns: Okay.
We definitely do want to try and offer Google
Play both for downloads and as well for publishing
in as many regions as possible.
But different countries have different legal
climates.
In some places, it's a bit easier for us to
go and open up shop than it is for others.
We definitely do want to go to expand to,
again, as many regions as possible.
It just takes a bit longer in some places
compared to others.
It would take a very long time to go explain
what these issues are for each country.
Just in general, we're working on it.
We're trying to get there as fast as possible.
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you again, Trevor.
Here is a GCM question.
GCM servers allow for a maximum of four different
collapse keys.
Suppose the server's already received and
stored messages with four different collapse
keys.
What happens with the next message?
If it's collapse key, it's not among those
four.
>>Nerieri: Okay.
The collapse key concept comes from C2DM where
every single message needs to specify one
collapse key.
The limit of four was to avoid people to use
infinite collapse keys to flood the devices.
We picked up four, which means that you have
four main topics for which you can update
your device with messages.
With GCM, we introduced a noncollapsible message,
so you don't have to specify the collapse
key.
If you need to send a big number of messages,
even if the devices are offline, you can use
that [indistinct].
It's important to note that it shouldn't be
used for messages that you do want to collapse,
like saying the same news as the very same
update, because we will deliver all those
messages down.
So you can still use this four collapse keys.
Now, we are thinking that this restriction
for GCM doesn't make much sense anymore, so
we might consider to increase the number of
collapse keys.
But to answer the question, what happens is
that you should not use more than four because
the results are not definite.
If you send messages with six different collapse
keys and the devices are offline, four of
those messages will make the device, and you're
not guaranteed which one of those four.
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you very much, Francesco.
All right.
Next question about GCM: I read somewhere
that GCM makes no guarantees regarding the
time to delivery or order of delivery of GCM
messages.
Okay.
Could you give us a rough estimate or target?
Any plans to provide stats once the system
is running smoothly?
>>Nerieri: Okay, one question at a time.
[chuckles] The time of delivery.
We do guarantee time of delivery for multiple
reasons.
One is that we have no idea if the device
is offline or online when we receive your
message.
If the device is offline, we just store it
and deliver it when it comes back online.
Two, we have no say on the latency introduced
by, for example, the mobile network between
our server and the device.
The numbers I gave are the speech, when I
had the speech at IO, was that roughly, we
take 95 milliseconds to process a message.
This is the time the GCM takes from the moment
it receives the message to the moment it sends
to the device.
Another part of the question--
>>Johns: The short answer there is that it's
pretty close to immediate.
>>Nerieri: Yes, it is.
>>Johns: Unless there's extenuating circumstances.
>>Malin: I would say in the best possible
case, it's nearly immediate, but the estimate
or target, a lot of it depends on what's going
on.
Whether the device is offline or online.
>>Nerieri: Correct.
But also, if your server sends a message in
Germany, and the user that receives the message
is somewhere else in the world, like in Taiwan,
we have quite a bit of routing to do from
that side of the world to the other one.
The latency can go out to 150 milliseconds.
But it's definitely, if the device is connected,
it's way below one second.
>>Malin: Right.
>>Nerieri: The other part was the order of
messages.
The way we send messages downstream is when
we receive a message, we store it, unless
the time to leave is zero.
In that case, we just send it down directly.
But if we store a message and a second one
comes, we deliver in that order.
But network, from your servers to our servers,
does not guarantee that if you send two messages
in the same millisecond, that we will receive
them in that exact order.
If we receive them swapped, then we'll deliver
them swapped.
>>Alexander Lucas: So does that mean that
it's guaranteed that we're sending them in
order?
>>Nerieri: In the order in which we receive
them.
>>Lucas: OK
>>Malin: That may not be the order in which
you sent them to our servers.
>>Nerieri: Correct.
Especially if you have a farm of servers that
sends messages at the very same time.
It depends on the network location.
>>Malin: I think in the last question was:
do we plan to provide stats on our--
>>Nerieri: We launched version 1 of Stats.
If you, as a developer, log into Android Developer
Console, you can see stats for GCM and C2DM
applications.
We provide metrics of how many messages are
being sent, how many are stored, collapsed,
or throttled.
If you had any errors in the request.
And also metrics for the registrations that
the user's device are connecting to our servers
for your application.
You can already see those.
We are working for providing a version 2 in
which you will be able to query the life of
a message.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay, thank you.
>>Reto Meier: Just before we go to the next
question, I'm getting a little bit of interference
from the two lavaliere mikes.
If you guys maybe want to turn those off and
just share the hand-helds with the guys next
to you.
>>Malin: All right.
We'll have to do that.
>>Johns: Actually, I guess we didn't have
to turn those off.
We could have just muted them, too, but--
Yes, we do have to share mikes now.
>>Malin: Right.
So that's why I have this yellow thing in
front of my face.
Next question from Moderator is for an app
working with sensitive data.
What solution would you recommend if I need
to show a login screen every time the app
comes from the background?
Related to that, is there an easy way to determine
if your app is currently in the background?
>>Johns: I think that this is actually a question
that's come up at least once before.
There's-- First off, to answer the question
of how do you determine if your app is in
the background, all Android applications have
a life cycle.
When they start up, you get a on-start or
on-create callback.
Then you'll get on-resume and so on and so
forth.
And finally, on-pause, on-stop.
These callbacks are what allows your app to
know what its current state is.
That's pretty much the answer to your question
as well, too.
If you want to go display a login dialog when
your app comes back up from the background,
if you just want to be on first launch, you
can put it in on-create.
If you want to make it so it appears when
it's coming back after being in the background
for a while, you can put it in on-resume.
It's just a matter of how you want to go and
display this.
Keep in mind that you don't want to display
your login dialog too frequently.
Be a bit cautious about how you do use this.
Also, it's worth noting, as far as your login
screen, don't go and launch that as a separate
activity.
There's some security implications there that--.
You can get it right if you're careful, but
it's very difficult to get right.
My recommendation there would be just to go
swap out your layout for your login form without
spawning a whole new activity.
I think that should answer your question.
>>Malin: I was going to add something, which
is that I have used apps that have [pause]
encrypted data in them.
They ask you for a login screen every time
you switch away from them and switch back,
which is a little bit of an annoyance.
>>Johns: Oh, it's very annoying.
To call out one app in particular, One Password.
I love the Mac version of it.
The Android version drives me absolutely nuts
because I log in to get my password, I switch
to the browser, I enter my password, I go
back to One Password, and it's locked again.
It hasn't even been 30 seconds.
The phone already has a lock screen, so I'd
say, at the very least, make this optional
because it's going to drive a lot of your
users nuts to the point where they might switch
to other apps.
Definitely don't make it mandatory.
Consider that if the user really does want
to keep their phone secure, they've probably
already set a passcode for the screen as well.
>>Malin: Right.
And in fairness to One Pass, I'm aware of
another password [clears throat] app that
I use which works exactly the same way.
I think it was designed with the idea that
you might leave the phone around without locking
it.
But I think it's better to just trust the
user that the user will know when he or she
wants to lock the phone itself.
Having to enter the password every time you
go in to get a different password is a user
annoyance.
That would be my comment.
>>Johns: Phones are much more personal devices
than computers.
Keep in mind, again, with a lot of the security
considerations you've made, you had to make
on a computer that wouldn't make sense in
the context of a phone because it is something
a user typically carries in their pocket.
And if you really, really do want to implement
this, consider making it a time delay and
not just an on-background delay.
>>Malin: Okay.
Any other comments?
[pause] Our next question from Moderator is
view.gettag performance versus custom holder
class for cells in a list view.
Storing view references using view.settag,
find view by IB, and then retrieving via view.gettag.
Simpler and less static.
I'm not really sure what that means.
[pause]
>>Johns: All right.
Well, I'll add you haven't used this for a
gridview, which behaves pretty much similar
to listview.
There's really no harm in using settag and
gettag.
It's there for you to go and store your custom
data, whatever that might be.
If you find that's an appropriate place to
put metadata, references to objects using,
etcetera, that's perfectly fine.
Just keep in mind, though, that your listview
cells get reused.
But as long as you keep that in mind, where
you decide to put your data doesn't really
make a difference.
>>Lucas: I'm trying to figure out what he
means by "versus custom holder."
I'm assuming that means something like external
hash table, keyed off of the row ID or something
like that.
One thing that you would run into in which
where view.settag would be a much better option
is that, as Trevor was saying, these get recycled.
If you were using an external hash table or
something like that, you could have 100 entries
in there with the view stored in there when
you only really need, like, seven.
That situation would take care of itself if
you just use the view.settag.
[pause]
>>Johns: All right.
Cool.
Next question, then.
>>Malin: Thank you very much, Alex.
The next question is from Moderator again:
with GCM, will there be any third party social
servers available for us to use, as otherwise,
stuff like Twitter Push, which is difficult
and pricey to implement.
I'm not really sure what's meant by third
party social servers.
I'll let Francesco--
>>Nerieri: The answer is no.
Google Cloud Messaging is a messaging service,
which means that your server can send messages
to the Cloud.
We deliver it to the device, but we don't
provide any kind of extra feature like bringing
down social messages or whatever.
If some developers could create a third party
service that other users could use, but it's
not Google.
>>Johns: The one thing that might be worth
mentioning there: one of the new features
we did add in GCM is that you can actually
have multiple API keys associated with a single
application.
As a completely hypothetical example, if Twitter
wanted to go and push messages directly to
your app, they could go and give you their
own API key.
You could add that as an authorized key for
your app, and then Twitter would be authorized
to send directly in to your app.
Right now, I'm not aware of any social services
that do that, but the functionality is there,
so if anybody does want to go and build that
out, the backend's already in place for that.
I got that right, right?
>>Nerieri: Yes.
>>Johns: Cool. [laughs]
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you very much, Trevor.
>>Meier: We had a question on the hangouts
from Matthew.
>>Malin: Okay, go ahead, Matthew.
[buzzing noise] Hello? [pause]
>>Matthew: Hello, this is Matt.
I had a question on the ADB tool.
When installing devices onto an emulator,
we're using code that's either generated by
ASM, not necessarily just compiled in Java.
You get errors like "Dexopt failed" or "Failed
UID changed."
I'm trying to find if there's a way to find
a general area that just lists where to go
when you encounter those types of errors.
I know what they mean, but-- [laughs] Assuming
Dexopt is kind of like a Java lying verify
error, but with much less details.
[pause]
>>Johns: Yeah, I'd say-- I mean, our documentation
there is somewhat sparse, partly because most
of the time, people don't interact with those
tools directly.
Anything that-- What causes error is normally
caught at an early level by the compiler and
such.
If you are going and trying to do your own
custom build, the chance of running into those
are a bit greater.
Unfortunately, like I said, not much documentation
there, at least on the Android Developer site.
Probably a good resource would be the Android
Developer's mailing list.
A lot of us are on the Android team within
Google.
We do keep an eye on that.
There's members of the framework team, members
of the build tools team.
We all stop in there every now and then.
If you do run into any of the more complicated
errors like that, you can just go ahead and
ask us directly.
It's certainly not as good as having documentation,
but it's probably the next best thing.
>>Matthew: Okay, thank you.
>>Jones: Yep.
>>Malin: Thank you.
Do we have anything else on-- Okay.
My producer says, "No", so let's move to Moderator:
I implemented a simple app for push notifications
to my phone, but I ran into a problem.
Boolean entries in the JSON sent to the GCM
server were converted into strings in the
intent extras.
Is that a bug or a technical limitation?
>>Nerieri: It's more like a technical limitation.
GCM, we opened the JSON protocol in GCM only,
but we want to be able for you guys to use
GCM on the very first release of push messaging,
which happened in Froyo devices.
Froyo devices, when we used C2DM for them,
they accepted all the plain text, in which
every parameter was string.
So we send down to the device only string
parameters.
It's a key-valued pair in which every single
value is represented as string.
When we opened the GCM interface, we had to
convert into string.
What we are thinking about is maybe force
the JSON to have only parameters with strings.
>>Malin: Okay.
Thank you very much, Francesco.
Next question from Moderator: Is it possible
that daily device installs also counts existing
devices that got a software update to a new
Android version?
On a certain day, I had 80 user installs and
450 device installs.
That was a spike on 4.03-4.04 device installs
that day.
>>Jones: Okay.
Google Play does make a distinction between--
Actually, hey, Reto, don't you want to switch
cameras?
Yeah.
[laughs] Google Play does make a distinction
between new installs versus upgrades.
As far as the data we're logging, we definitely
do know the difference between the two of
them.
I'm certainly not going to rule off the possibility
that there is a bug in our logging pipeline,
but, to my knowledge, assuming everything
is working the way it was designed, those
installs should be different.
It's entirely-- It's possible, too, that maybe
you just got a bunch of traffic from some
other source and your update may, [indistinct],
notice your app.
If you [pause] maybe install something like
Google Analytics, which will get you a little
bit more visibility into where your users
are coming from, how many unique users you
have, that might help distinguish between
the two of those.
I've certainly never heard of updates being
counted as new installs, so I'm really inclined
to think that actually, those are new installs
for some reason with your app.
Like I said, give Google Analytics a try,
see if that helps.
At least you'll distinguish where those users
are coming from.
It'll tell you things like refers.
Lots of really GC stats there.
All right.
>>Malin: Thank you, Trevor.
>>Jones: I just want to say, I stole Alex's
thunder.
He's the analytics guy.
[laughter]
>>Lucas: It's all right.
I'm just glad more people know on the scene
know that I noticed.
I'm not the only one.
>>Malin: Great.
Regarding GCM, what ports need to be opened
on our server behind firewall?
Only HTTPS, which is 443, or 5228, 5229 and
5230, or all of them?
>>Nerieri: Okay, so if your server is the
one that sends the messages and the only piece
that you want to use for GCM, in this case,
then the port 43 is the only one you need.
But if you have devices that need to receive
messages, then the port you want to open your
firewall is 5228, which is enough for now,
but you might want to open as well 5229, 5230,
because we might use those in the future.
>>Malin: Okay.
Great.
Thank you very much.
Next question off of Moderator: are there
docs coming up for using Create App Engine
Backends option in GPE?
There was a great talk in Google IO about
the same thing, but until now, no docs have
been released.
When I click Google Create App Engine Backend,
it exits with an error.
>>Lucas: I can take a shot at this.
I'm assuming that you're referring to the
Create App Engine Backend for an Android application
and you haven't just randomly put an App Engine
question in an unrelated Android talk.
That plug-in, that particular function, uses
C2DM to communicate back down to the Android
device.
Given the C2DM is now deprecated, I'm not
actually sure what the future of that plug-in
is off the top of my head.
I can look into it.
[buzzing noise] But for the time being, I
know that there are documents.
If you already have a C2DM account, there
is documentation up.
There is-- The GPE plug-in has its own page
that you can look at.
There's also a page up on Android training.
I can't really say anything about the error
you're seeing without knowing what the actual--
>>Jones: Yeah, as general guidelines, when
you guys see an error and you want to ask
us, it helps if you actually tell us what
the error is.
[laughs] But more general, just talking about
the plug-in, I'm not aware of any plans to
deprecate it.
I think, if something isn't working, I think
that's just a legitimate bug.
Please file a bug report and we'll look into
it.
In general, b.android.com is the Android bug
tracker.
Or, of course, leave a comment here with additional
information.
But again, we do need to know the actual error.
All right.
Joe?
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you very much, gentlemen.
Next question is: are you planning on selling
the ADK 2012 at some point in time for those
who couldn't make IO?
If not, what would you say is the next best
alternative?
Go ahead, Trevor.
>>Jones: All right.
Right now, I'm not aware of any plans to have
Google selling the ADK version too directly.
That being said, we have published all of
the schematics and various board layout files
online.
Anybody who does want to go and make one,
everything is open source.
I want to say it's Creative Commons.
Don't quote me on that.
Check the license associated with it, but
it is released under permissive license.
Anybody who does want to actually go and manufacture
more of these boards, just go ahead, download
them from our website.
At some point in the future, I suspect you'll
actually see some on the market from somebody
who's not Google who's actually gone and reproduced
them.
They do take-- For those of you haven't seen
it, it's actually a really cool design.
They took the ADK and built this really neat
touch sensitive alarm clock around it.
When you actually want to go and build it,
you actually pop it open, it has some magnets,
and rip the ADK out of it.
It's really cool, but it's also a lot of work
to build.
I think it'll probably take a little bit before
people actually release the exact same ADK.
That being said, I'm sure you'll also see
some non-alarm clock ADKs for sale as well,
for somebody who just wants a simpler, hardware
platform to go and build on top of.
>>Lucas: I just want to add: the ADK that
we gave away last year was followed up within
a couple months by several third parties writing
their own ADKs and selling their own ADKs.
Many of them were more impressive than the
one that we gave away.
I wouldn't worry too much about getting your
hands on one of the ones that we gave away
at IO.
Just go to the website and keep your ears
open.
Check out Maker Faire-type communities.
More awesome stuff that's better than what
we gave away will probably be coming down
the pipe.
>>Malin: Good answers.
Thank you very much.
Let's go down here to the next Moderator question.
This is going to be one that Francesco can
answer: why are GCM multicast messages restricted
to 1000 registration IDs?
>>Nerieri: As opposed to 1001? [laughs] No.
It's actually a good question.
The API is a multicast messaging, which means
it's not broadcast, which means you don't
want to send the message to everybody.
So we had to come up with a number.
Now, the number is 1000.
It's the maximum we wanted to go at the beginning
because we see spikes.
Every time we receive messages, we can have
a QPS.
In C2DM, we had a very nice curve with QPS.
But now we can have spikes of people sending
1000 messages in one request, which is very
difficult to allocate for our resources.
We wanted to give this kind of API because
it's good for our developers to be able to,
in one request, address multiple devices.
But we had to come up with a number, and this
number was 1000.
>>Malin: Okay.
That's a good enough answer, I think.
>>Nerieri: I hope.
>>Malin: Yeah.
I hope that answers your question.
If not, if you've got any other information
that causes you to ask this, we'd be interested
in hearing it.
Meanwhile, we'll move on to the next question:
I have knowledge of Android SDK, Android tools,
Jenkins, Ant, Miavan, XML, and JSON.
>>Lucas: I think they mean Maven.
>>Malin: Maven.
Okay, yeah, that's probably true.
Didn't think about that.
What else does an Android developer need to
know to enhance his or her technical skills?
[pause]
>>Lucas: Everything!
>>Jones: Yeah, that's quite the question there.
>>Lucas: Yeah.
One thing I do notice missing from the list
is SQL.
For persistence storage, we use a SQLite database.
I would throw that on the list of things to
cover.
Other than that, that is quite a broad question.
>>Jones: Yeah.
Open GL would be a very good topic to learn,
just because at some point, you'll probably
want to do something 3D.
If not, a full-fledged 3D game, maybe you
just want to go and build some effects into
your application.
Open GL tends to be a very good tool for that.
In addition, just general computer graphics.
If Open GL doesn't do what you need to do,
you're going to be stuck with something like
a canvas.
Knowing how to actually go and do things efficiently
in that context is a good skill.
More broadly speaking, you're going to want
to know how to do things with web services,
so understanding concepts like rest, o/off,
things like that, very useful to know.
Really, it's a very broad question here.
[laughs] I could just go down the list all
day.
But yeah, I'd say you've already got a pretty
strong foundation there.
It really depends on what it is you want to
build.
I mentioned Open GL.
Maybe that has no bearing in your-- I don't
know.
I don't know what you want to do.
But I'd say you already have a pretty strong
technical foundation with what you've listed.
>>Malin: I would certainly agree with that.
I would also say that there's really no end
to the answer because you can't ever tell
what you're going to need to know.
A lot of it, to my mind, depends on what you're
trying to accomplish.
If you are trying to get a position someplace
with a company that's doing something in particular,
then I would look at what that company is
doing, what type of applications base it's
in.
If it's very data-oriented, you probably want
to look at something like SQL.
Or, you may want to look at statistics and
learn something about how statistics and analytics
are done in this base.
On the other hand, if you want to be a contractor
and independent developer, one of the things
you're probably going to have to do is decide
on what's most in demand and then focus on
those areas.
You may have to pick up technical skills along
the way as you're doing a contract.
There's no way to say that you're ever finished
with learning stuff.
That's certainly true.
[pause]
>>Jones: I think that's a pretty good answer.
>>Malin: Yeah.
I mean, Trevor covered a lot of the things
that I would have covered, especially Open
GL.
I think that's a really good answer.
Let's move on: is there a rough estimate for
when C2DM will be turned off?
I think we've got the expert here that maybe
will give us an answer.
>>Nerieri: C2DM is deprecated, which means
we don't accept any more sign-ups, nor quota
requests.
We do not want to break your applications,
so we will give, if we will ever turn the
services down, we will give heads up way ahead
of time.
At least a year before we decide to do so.
This said, I would urge you to migrate to
the new system before you run into quota issues
or if you need to use new APIs or the client
login, which is being deprecated.
It will actually be deprecated.
>>Jones: Just to follow up on that.
Whenever we deprecate an API, it is a good
idea to go and take a look for alternatives.
The alternative in this case would be GCM
and to move there as quickly as you can.
Again, we don't want to break your app.
It's not going to disappear any time in the
near future.
You do have time to do a nice, orderly migration.
But please don't wait to migrate until we
actually say the servers are going away, because
by then, you'll be in a rush.
Start your migration to GCM now, and then
you'll be in good shape for when they do eventually
get turned off in the future.
[pause]
>>Malin: Great, thank you.
Next question.
Okay, if we thought the one before was open
ended: I'm trying to learn Java.
Can you recommend some books or videos, etcetera?
>>Lucas: I'm sure we're all going to have
opinions on this one, but I'm going to take
a start.
The part that you didn't give us that's really
important is: are you an experienced or intermediate
programmer who just hasn't been exposed to
Java yet, or are you not used to programming?
If you're already familiar with programming,
I got a lot of value out of a book called
Core Java.
Also one-- I'm blanking on the name, maybe
you guys can help-- by Josh Bloch.
It had a lot of really good design patterns.
>>Malin: Effective Java.
>>Lucas: Effective Java.
Thank you, Joe.
Really good book, but difficult to digest
if you are not already familiar with programming.
If you're a new programmer, it's been pretty--
I'm pretty sure pretty close to a decade since
any of us have been new to programming.
If we knew good resources a decade ago, they're
out of date by now.
Anyone else want to take a crack at this?
>>Jones: Yeah, I'm actually going to take
an opposing stance here and say that I've
hated every Java book I've ever read.
[laughter] That being said, there's some amazing
tutorials online.
What used to be the Sun website is now the
Oracle website.
They have a lot of Java tutorials there.
All of them are actually really well-written.
I can't recommend them highly enough.
You go take a look at those, perhaps.
They have-- Most of them are in tutorial format.
They're written by the guys who did a lot
of the initial work on the Java language.
That'd be my recommendation.
Also, if you are going to branch out into
Android, I can recommend a very good Android
book, which would be the one written by the
guy sitting on the other end of the camera
right now, Reto Meier.
It's an Android for application development.
He's not on camera, so he can't really speak
to it, but I'll give him my recommendation
from this side of the camera.
>>Malin: I would agree with Trevor's recommendation.
I would also say that the books and videos
and everything is going to depend a lot on
where you're coming from.
If you've done programming and you're coming
from another language, you may want to take
a look at books out there.
I'm sure there is some book that is like "Java
programming for C programmers" or something
like that.
If you just Google that, you may find something
that will help you.
If you are not familiar with object-oriented
programming, then you may want to look at
something that's a little bit more elementary
that covers that as well as Java from the
point of view of somebody just starting out.
I happen to have a book called Java in a Nutshell,
which is an O'Reilly book.
The reason I have it is that it does cover--
It is a good introduction in the sense that
it takes you from very simple to very complex,
but it's also a really great reference.
Since I can't claim to be a Java expert, I
always have it sitting around in case I need
to look up something, which I find very easy
to do in that particular book.
The only other thing I can think of is that
a lot of things these days are discussed in
terms of general terminology for computer
science related to programming languages.
You may want to look at books that are just
in general about object-oriented programming
and design patterns.
I sometimes read a book called Design Patterns,
which is at least a decade old, if not 20
years old at this point.
But it's a good summary.
Unfortunately in C++ rather than Java.
The standard algorithms and design patterns
for creating things in any programming language.
That's worth having on your bookshelf.
>>Jones: Actually, Francesco, since you're
a guest today, what's your opinion?
Was there any books or anything you found
particularly good when you started out learning
Java for the first time?
>>Nerieri: You know, I learned Java when I
was in Italy.
The books there were different.
[laughter] My opinion is if you're new to
a programming language, I would not start
with the language itself.
I would start learning [mike gives out] like
suggested, because you can build up the foundation
of programming skills, which will help you
then pick up a language, which is Java, C,
or Python, or whatever, much quicker and faster.
I have a deeper understanding of the code
[mike gives out] rather than having an approach
of, "I know this Java library, so I'm going
to use that" without really understanding
what's happening.
>>Jones: Okay, thank you very much.
>>Malin: Since we're on this topic that is
dear to my heart, I'll say one more thing
about this, which is-- sorry-- which is that
the fastest way to learn any programming language
is to set yourself a project.
I thought I knew Java really well until I
started working on Android.
Then I really learned Java, because you learn
something very fast if you have to work in
it every day and if you've got a target.
At least, that's my way of learning.
Look at the ways you've learned other things,
and follow that.
If you learn out of a book, then get a book.
If you learn by doing, then I would say, "Go
do something."
[pause]
>>Jones: All right.
>>Malin: Okay, let's move on.
The next question is: is Semantic Zoom, as
implemented in ICS Calendar, a recommended
pattern to use in our own apps?
>>Jones: I actually don't know what Semantic
Zoom is.
>>Malin: Yeah, I don't either.
Sorry.
>>Lucas: It's this.
>>Malin: Ah, okay.
I think what the question means is: is expanding
with a two finger gesture a recommended pattern
to use in your own apps?
>>Jones: Unfortunately, we don't have our
capture device hooked up, otherwise we'd actually
show you what Alex just showed us.
He took two fingers and just was able to drag
up and down.
The calendar view expanded and contracted
as he did that.
>>Lucas: Specifically, one element of the
view expanded and everything else stayed the
same, which I assume is what they mean by
Semantic Zoom.
A recommended pattern.
I don't think it's an official recommendation
at this point.
I would check the Android Design Guide for
that.
But it looks neat.
[laughter] I think it improves usability,
at least for the calendar app.
It's definitely not a discouraged pattern,
but I don't think it's an official pattern
yet, either.
It's just a neat thing that's out there.
>>Malin: I can answer specifically for something
I do know about: notifications.
Jelly Bean Notifications implement that feature
as part of the API now.
Notifications at least used to be what we
call one-u, which is a height of about, I
think it's 64 DP.
But now we feature an expanded notification.
If you do a gesture like stretching the boundaries
of the notification apart or some other gestures,
you'll expand it to what's called a 4-U notification
with a lot more space.
It's 256 DP.
That's a zoom multi-- What I would call a
multi-touch zoom.
That's an official part of Notification UI
at this point.
It's worth looking into.
>>Jones: On the broader topic of UI design
patterns.
There's certainly a lot of stuff that we try
that we think looks really cool or greatly
improves the usability of the system.
Hopefully the two at the same time.
We give those a try in our own apps.
We're a bit more conservative with the official
design guidelines, because once we write something
down there, it's more or less set in stone.
Developers go and they build up their apps
using those patterns.
So we want to make sure that anything we actually
go and write down is something that we're
really happy with.
I think that this particular pattern that
was mentioned in the question has not actually
been added to our UI guideline, as Alex mentioned.
If you want to go and be on the leading edge,
by all means try to make your app work on
the system.
I think it's a very good goal.
I think you can't go wrong.
That being said, don't be surprised if, in
the next release, some of these things change
out from underneath you.
It's just like using undocumented API.
That's right.
These things are still in flux.
Actually, I take it back.
It's not as bad as [mike gives out] in API,
that's a horrible thing.
Don't ever do it.
[laughs] But no.
I don't think you can go wrong in this case
if you just want to make something that looks
like the system.
Just keep an eye out what comes for you.
When the K release comes out, whatever that
happens to be called, make sure that that
behavior hasn't changed.
>>Lucas: I would also add that this is a shiny,
visually appealing feature that doesn't necessarily
mean it's appropriate all the time.
In general, I agree with Trevor, that if you
want to look like the system, you can't really
go wrong.
But we also put a lot of effort into making
visually appealing little effects like that,
where appropriate.
>>Jones: That's true.
There is a guideline that you want to have
lots of playful visual flourishes.
It makes your app feel more alive.
It makes your users happy.
Even if things aren't necessarily documented
as official patterns, if it makes sense in
the context of your app and follows the spirit
of the system-- The overarching goal there
is something we have written down.
>>Lucas: I was actually more referring to--
again, general, I agree-- I was more referring
to being cautious when using a feature like
that.
Don't set up a text view where you use that
feature and expand one word so it overlaps
all the other words, because that would be--
>>Jones: Right, you have to make sure it's
usable.
You have to make sure it actually makes sense.
>>Lucas: Exactly.
>>Jones: But at the same time, having something
that is usable and makes sense, but is fun,
is a good thing.
Case in point, Google+.
When I get an event invitation, it folds out
like an actual event card, like a little piece
of paper unraveling.
It has no practical use, but it looks cool
and it makes people happy.
It doesn't hurt usability, at the very least.
It actually might even help, because it helps
explain what's going on.
>>Malin: Right.
I would add that some of these things are
sort of subtle, but they're force multipliers.
That means that you have immediate ability
to look at information in depth and take action
without having to go to another activity or
application.
For instance, in Notifications, you can click
buttons and look at more than one email message.
That's a force multiplier because what it
means is you're not forcing the user to go
into email to look at what's going on or go
into a music player or a chat system.
They can look at it right from the notifications.
They can look at a calendar event in detail
without having to switch to a separate activity
to look at it.
That's very powerful.
It makes things look-- It's easy to use, but
it means that there's less work for the user.
I have to give credit to Daniel Sandler for
that.
Yes, go ahead.
>>Audience member: I've got a question about
the impact servers.
Can you use content observers [inaudible]
>>Malin: The question was: can you use content
observer instead of content provider to monitor
a database?
If not, can you suggest another way of monitoring
This sounds like a familiar question.
I think we've discussed this before.
If not officially in Developer Office Hours,
amongst ourselves.
I'm not sure what the answer is.
Anybody got an idea?
[pause]
>>Jones: As far as content observer versus
content provider, unfortunately, I don't know
the answer off the top of my head either.
I'm drawing a blank.
There's certainly more than one way to go
and read data out of a database.
At the end, it's all going to boil down to
a SQL statement somewhere.
It's just what design pattern do you use to
go and retrieve that data and make it accessible
to everything else.
Reto, you literally wrote the book on this,
so what's your thoughts?
>>Meier: I think the key here is what he's
asking is, specifically-- A content observer
what you use when you want to be able to monitor
a database with changes.
>>Malin: If you want a content observer that
monitors a cursor.
>>Meier: Exactly.
>>Malin: Right.
His question is: can you use it for a monitor
a cursor from a database, rather than from
a content provider?
>>Malin: As far as I know, you should be able
to.
>>Jones: Yeah, a cursor's a cursor.
>>Malin: Yeah, a cursor is a cursor.
A content observer.
There's an observer on cursors that I think
is independent of content providers.
>>Meier: That's my understanding as well,
but--
>>Malin: Right.
The easy answer is: look in cursor, and if
cursor has a set content observer method on
it, then you can do it, because that's how
you would do it, is set a content observer
for a cursor that comes from the database.
Content provider, all that it really does
for SQL databases, is encapsulate an SQLite
database.
The SQLite database returns the cursor and
the content provider returns that cursor to
the calling component.
So really, that's all the difference that
there is.
There's nothing magic about a content provider
that automatically does an observation.
[pause] Anybody else?
Okay.
>>Jones: It's actually probably a good time
to mention that we have about 15 minutes left.
If anybody does want to go and ask us any
live questions, please jump into our Hangout.
We'd be happy to have you on the air.
Even if your mike doesn't work, feel free
to hop on anyway.
You can go ahead and type your question out
to us and we can go ahead and ask our panel
of experts here in the room.
GCM questions or just Android questions in
general.
We're happy to take any of them.
>>Malin: That's a good point.
>>Meier: I've been keeping an eye on the Google+
event livestream as well.
If you have any questions, you can talk to
me [inaudible]
>>Malin: Right.
>>Meier: One of these is from Noulesh, who
asks: is it a good idea to have two different
versions of the AAP plugin and FDK tools running
two separate fields.
Eg, SPN trunk could be running on ADT 20 and
SPK 20 tools, and Branch could be running
ADT 15 and SDK 15.
Are there any issues with this?
>>Malin: Okay.
The question is: is it a good idea to run
separate versions of ADT on separate builds?
The answer is-- My answer would be you certainly
can't do it in the same version of Eclipse,
because those are plug-ins.
I don't think you can have more than one ADT
plug-in in the same version of Eclipse You
certainly would run into problems.
But if you want to have more than one instance
of Eclipse on your system, then you should
be able to do it.
>>Jones: There is one problem I can see with
all this.
The goal here is not only to have different
versions of ADT, but also different versions
of the Android framework running, too.
Correct?
>>Malin: Right.
>>Jones: In that case, there are different
versions of ADB server.
The different versions of the framework are
going to try to launch different versions
of ADB server.
That's going to cause conflicts.
I think even if you're running your different
versions of the SDK inside of different versions
of the ADT inside of different versions of
Eclipse, at the end of the day, you can only
have one version of ADB server running.
That's where you're going to run into problems.
>>Malin: Yeah, that is a good point.
You'd probably have to do a lot of fiddling
around with path variables and environment
variables in order to get it to work correctly.
It's probably not worth doing.
I would think that probably what you want
to do, if you're just trying to aim at different
platforms, is set up for the highest level
platform.
Then you can always aim to a lower API if
you want to check for API compatibility.
>>Jones: Yeah, I'll add one additional data
point here.
Here in the Android team, we work with a lot
of different versions of the Android framework.
I have never installed more than one copy
of ADT.
I think that's not the right approach here.
I think the right approach: have one version
of FDK tools, one version of ADT, and, like
Joe said, just go ahead and switch what your
build targets are.
That's a perfectly supported work flow.
[pause]
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you.
Next question from Moderator: Google Maps
home to work feature.
Is there an API available for developers to
access this data?
Intents or provider or something?
I'm researching location tracking for my app.
I don't know exactly what the question means,
but I assume that the respondent means the
thing that tells you how long it's going to
take you to get from your home to work and
vice versa.
>>Jones: Right, I think so too, which I believe,
actually, was something-- I think that's part
of the whole latitude umbrella, where it's
actually going and keeping track of where
you are and reporting it to your friends and
building a location service on top of that.
The answer, to my knowledge, is no, we don't
have an API for that.
We do have location manager.
You can get both fine-grained GPS location
data as well as the coarser-grained WiFi-based
data as well.
But we don't actually have the API say, "Where
is my detect at home, where is my detect at
work, etcetera."
>>Lucas: I would say, actually, if there is
an API for that, we're the wrong one's to
ask because we don't run-- or we don't write
latitude or Google Maps.
I believe Maps API has their own office hours.
That would be the right place to ask.
>>Malin: Yeah.
I'm familiar with the current V1 version of
the Maps API for Android, and I don't think
that it has anything like this in it.
>>Jones: No, it doesn't.
>>Malin: But there's also-- I think this is
not a feature of that component.
I think this is more a feature of the Maps
app and the latitude API-- the latitude app.
I don't think that they have APIs available.
So.
Go ahead.
>>Meier: There is a latitude API, I think.
>>Malin: Is there?
Hmm.
>>Jones: There is a latitude API, but I think
it's more for just reporting what your location
is.
I don't think-- At least, the last time I
looked at it, which admittedly was quite a
while ago, it didn't have anything "get your
autodetected home and work locations."
>>Malin: Okay.
Well, I stand corrected, which is pretty much
par for the course today.
>>Jones: No, no.
The answer is there's no API for this.
>>Malin: Right.
The answer for this particular question is
there is no API.
Sorry.
If you've got any more particular questions,
you can send them into us or call on-- get
online and talk to us about it.
There may be something that we're missing
that-- I feel like there's more to this question
that we haven't answered.
I just want to leave that open.
Next question from Moderator is: I'm using
the following function to get all view IBs
versus calling find view by IB multiple times,
which does a very similar traversal.
And he has it in a link.
I'm guessing this is faster if you have a
high IB versus non IB view group.
Unfortunately, we don't-- I don't have off-hand
the link available.
Let me go look in the link and see if it's--
[pause] I'm getting a redirect.
It has something called a create resource
map. [pause]
>>Jones: Okay, he's literally just iterating
through all the children inside a view group.
Then it creates this resource map, which is--
I'm not sure what data structure that is there.
>>Malin: I can't tell off-hand, but I think
what's he's just--
>>Jones: Oh, here we go.
He's actually-- If resource ID is not equal
to view.noid, and then he sets-- All right.
>>Malin: Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
>>Jones: Honestly, I think you're over-thinking
things a bit.
Find view by id is normally the right way
to do this.
Unless you're seeing actual concrete performance
problems, which you can use-- You can find
that out by using profiling tools.
Things like Trace View.
Unless you're actually seeing a negative performant
hit there, I'd say this is probably a case
of premature optimization.
It seems like going a bit overboard to me.
I've never seen anyone go out of their way
to go in and scan through all your childviews
like that.
Seems a little off.
But that being said, I'm not going to discount
the possibility that it might be more-- it
might be faster in certain situations, which
really just depend on how you're using it.
But again, unless you're seeing a performance
impact, it seems like code you might not even
need to worry about.
>>Lucas: I would say that if you are seeing
a performance impact and that's actually making
it faster, the only way I can see that being
true is if your view IR key is so complicated
and nested that you have much bigger fish
to fry.
>>Jones: Yeah, if you have hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of views that you're trying to
call find view by ID on, I'm really terrified
to think what you're view hierarchy actually
looks like.
>>Lucas: If it's a--
>>Jones: You're going to spend more time rendering
than you're going to spend searching.
>>Lucas: Right.
>>Malin: Right.
Okay.
Let's move on here.
How does the Tablet layout of Google Play
manage to display two pages at once when you've
scrolled over to the category section of the
view pager?
Hmm.
>>Lucas: I don't have a Tablet on hand.
>>Jones: Yeah, I'm not sure what you mean
by display two pages at once.
I suspect they've just gone and created a
view that displays both sets of information
at once.
It could be done using fragments.
That's the sort of thing that they're designed
to be very good at.
You can certainly stick fragments inside of
a view pager.
I think that's the answer: the magic of fragments.
>>Malin: Okay.
Thank you.
Next question from Moderator: do you have
any plans on integrating Facebook or Twitter
in Android as Apple did with Twitter?
[buzzing noise] Hmm.
>>Jones: No comment.
[laughs]
>>Malin: Yeah.
>>Lucas: Yeah.
This falls under the category of "we don't
disclose roadmap."
>>Malin: Right.
>>Lucas: This would be a huge roadmap question.
>>Jones: Yeah.
Is our tardis fixed, by any chance?
>>Malin: Nope.
>>Jones: All right.
Yeah, we can't--
>>Malin: Nothing we can do.
The time machine is not working.
we can't tell you about things that we may
or may not do in the future.
>>Jones: Yeah, it's stuck on the shelf, not
moving anywhere.
>>Malin: Right.
>>Jones: Sometimes it has cookies inside,
but--
>>Malin: Okay, next question: does the remote
control client API only support the flag key
median next, flag key media pause, and flag
key media previous controls?
Other flags do not seem to show up.
>>Jones: Without looking at that API, on the
top of my head, I'm not sure any of us know
the answer.
I'm not sure what you mean by "don't show
up", either.
Do you mean it doesn't work or it's not in
the documentation?
>>Meier: I think he probably means that it's
not visible on the lock screen.
So you just have next, previous, and pause.
>>Jones: Ah.
Well, if they don't show up, that's probably
a good indication they don't work.
>>Malin: Yeah.
Okay.
Since we're getting low on time, we'll move
on.
I'm looking for a way to overlay a drop shadow
on a scroll view as described here, with a
link.
How can I overlay a dropshot onto a scroll
view?
Is this possible?
It looks as if the holo.lite action bar does
the same.
[pause] Any answers?
Are you waiting for--
>>Jones: I was waiting for the link.
But I'm not sure I actually know the answer,
having never tried to overlay shadow on top
of a scroll view.
>>Malin: I think that what he's trying-- It
shows a layout, and he's trying to put a drop
shadow on top of something that's in the details.
My intention that has another layout above
and outside the scroll view.
It stays at the top whilst scrolling the content
in the scroll view.
The scroll view should have a drop shadow
overlay if the top, which appears to be from
the layout of--
>>Jones: Well, you certainly can place views
on top of other views.
There is an implied Z order.
I think, depending on which type of [indistinct]
major you're using, sometimes you can even
specify the Z order, if I remember correctly.
But if that's the case, then just create a
shadow as a drawable, with an alpha layer.
Problem solved.
Short of that, there are other things you
can do to try and fake that, but I'm not thinking
of anything that will work really well in
the case of a scroll view.
Actually, no.
There is a-- what's the word I'm looking for?--
a heading section on scroll views where you
can actually go and-- Normally, it's designed
to go and have a title for your scroll view,
but you could put a drawable in there to put
your shadow as well.
That's a hack, but it'll work.
>>Malin: Yeah.
It's not-- I mean, from what I'm looking at
here, it's not really clear to me whether
he's trying to put the drop shadow on the
scroll view or on the title above the scroll
view.
I can't really tell.
>>Jones: If you're putting it on the title
above the scroll view, that's even easier.
Then you just place a drawable at the bottom.
The one thing that makes the scroll view difficult
is it's going to move.
But I think-- To me, you're putting whatever
your green box is on top of your scroll view.
Taking advantage of Z order is probably the
easiest option.
>>Malin: I think that's a good answer.
Okay, let's see if we can move on.
Next question-- sorry.
Okay.
We're going to have to make this the last
question, my producer tells me.
So: how can I notify each fragment in the
view pager, which is linked to a tab-post
to refresh its view data, following the lotoor
finishing in the main activity? [pause]
>>Lucas: A view pager is linked to a tab-post?
>>Malin: Yeah.
How can I notify each fragment in a view pager
linked to a tab-post to refresh its view data
following the lotoor finishing in the main
activity?
>>Jones: Generally speaking, the way you want
to go and communicate with fragments is using--
Define and interface and just make a call
to all of your fragments.
Then have your fragments go and update what's
inside of them.
I usually recommend against reaching inside
of fragments to go and try to manipulate whatever
view components are inside of it, because
then you're breaking encapsulation.
The idea with a fragment is you can go and
swap it out with other fragments as needed.
It is portable.
Once you go and start modifying the content
of fragments, you've broken that portability.
Short answer: send a message to your fragment
and have the fragment update itself.
Anybody else have any insight on that?
>>Malin: No.
He has posted a large set of code on Stack
Overflow that we could go take a look at in
more detail, but--
>>Jones: Probably not in the 30 seconds that
we have left.
>>Malin: Yeah, unfortunately.
Sorry.
>>Lucas: I think we're out of time.
>>Malin: Sorry we're out of time.
But we are out of time.
We'll have to take a look at it in Stack Overflow.
Hopefully, somebody else can step in and take
a look at it as well.
I encourage everybody else in the Android
developer world to go to Stack Overflow, take
a look at this question, see if you've got
any ideas about what's going on.
>>Jones: That's a lot of people.
>>Malin: Yes.
[laughter] Crowd-sourcing the answer.
And on that note, I think we're done for today.
I want to thank Francesco for showing up and
answering GCM questions.
>>Nerieri: Thank you, guys.
>>Malin: And Trevor and Alex for supporting
me, and Reto for running all the equipment
to bring this to you.
On that note, goodbye.
>>Jones: See ya, everyone.